zurück bei bilder malen mit dem
bekanntesten und zugleich umstrittensten
diplomaten in deutschland andré wenig
das ist die stimme das ist das gesicht
der ukraine hier in deutschland der
kämpft das wissen sie wie ein löwe für
sein land und provoziert dabei hat viele
menschen auch hier in deutschland
aufgeregt damit und jetzt soll schluss
sein für mini countryman ich könnte als
botschafter deutschland bald verlassen
nach kiew zurück gehen mehr weiß unser
bild reporter paul ronzheimer mit diesen
brandheiße news andrej melik zurück nach
kiew weg aus deutschland wann warum
ja das ist das was wir erfahren haben
aus mehreren quellen sowohl aus dem
außenministerium rund um den präsidenten
die debatte um die läuft schon länger
also die frage wie viel ist gut und wie
sehr muss ich ein diplomat zurückhaltend
anfangs war es so dass der präsident
insbesondere massiv hinter ihm stand und
auch die regierung gesagt hat ist gut
dass da mal jemand drauf haut jetzt
zuletzt hatte es aber debatten gegeben
um stefan bandera den früheren einstigen
ukrainischen nationalisten der für die
unabhängigkeit der ukraine aber eben
auch als antisemit jemand der dort den
manic verteidigt hat und der am ende
unter diese debatte die dazu geführt hat
dass ist heftige aufregung gab und jetzt
ist es so dass wir hören dass manic aus
deutschland aus deutschland gehen könnte
dass er nach kiew kommt im gespräch ist
dass er stellvertretender außenminister
wird das ist noch nicht so ganz klar
definitiv ist es aber so dass er gehen
soll dass es der planer ist bereits seit
acht jahren botschafter also
normalerweise ist man vier jahre oder
maximal sechs jahre im amt also die
regulären laufzeit ist auch schon längst
überschritten bei anderen männer lass
uns noch mal reinschauen in einige der
aussagen über die sich viele hier in
deutschland auch erregt haben in den
letzten wochen vor drei wochen war hier
im studio zuletzt andrej melik der
botschafter der ukraine bei den
richtigen fragen und hat das gesagt
die meisten ukraine kehren zurück schon
längst es sind mehr menschen die abreise
aus diesem land die zu ihnen kommen und
ich glaube dass sie sich auch gedanken
machen sollten über die gründe wenn ich
jetzt diese runde mal mir anhöre ich
glaube das ist auch klar wie viele
gräber wieso sie keine lust haben
hierzubleiben
sie fühlen sich nicht viel raum ein
viele ukraine die sich nicht mehr
willkommen fühlt noch das hat für
aufregung gesorgt da ist dann andre
melnik anschließend stück zurück
gerudert hat sich auch für einige
aussagen entschuldigt später beschreibt
uns noch mal diesen typen diesen
botschafter der wie ich schon gesagt
habe doch gekämpft hat auch für sein
land wie ein löwe und gleichzeitig so
vielen irgendwie vielleicht auch die
sehr empfindlich waren hier in
deutschland laufen schütz getreten ist
andrej melik war ein diplomatischer
kämpfer wie sie sonst nicht nochmal gibt
kann das muss man so sagen von anfang an
und eben nicht erst zu beginn des
krieges sondern seit 2004 10 seitdem die
annexion auf der krim passiert ist
seitdem ist die angriffe im osten gab wo
er schon russische soldaten waren
seitdem haut andrej melik auf den putz
steinmeier kritisiert er hat merkel
kritisiert er kritisiert jetzt stolz und
macht das mit einer besonderen wortwahl
nicht wie ein diplomat sondern eher wie
jemand der die wahrheit sozusagen
aussprechen wird zumindest die wahrheit
wie er sie empfindet und angemeldet hat
natürlich wahnsinnig gelitten in den
letzten monaten dass er der ja in
deutschland ist und immer wieder
gekämpft hat so wenig gehört wurde
zumindest am anfang was waffen angehen
was unterstützung anging und andrej
melik ist das schier verzweifelt und die
emotionen kochen dann natürlich auch bei
einem diplomaten hoch bei einem
botschafter und deswegen auf dieser
klartext sicherlich da sind mal ein paar
dinge gefallen du hast das eine beispiel
gerade genannt das ja vielleicht etwas
zu viel war aus sicht der deutschen aber
es gab auch viele die gesagt haben er
trifft genau den richtigen ton nur
dieser ton neben der iss ist der jetzt
zumindest in der letzten woche für
heftige kritik aus polen aus israel
gesorgt hat eben weil er den einstigen
ja nationalistenführer bandera
verteidigt hat und das war dann auch für
das ukrainische außenministerium zu viel
die sich dann wiederum distanziert haben
von ihm weil das so viel aufruhr in
polen in israel und in deutschland
ausbilden das ist also die news von dir
in dieser stunde paul ronzheimer
berichtet dass andrej melik der so
umstrittene botschafter der ukraine hier
in deutschland jetzt wohl deutschland
den rücken kehren wird und zurückkehren
wird in die ukraine nach kiew ganz kurz
kessler ersatz vladimir klitschko
vielleicht
ich glaube wladimir klitschko wäre nicht
bereit den botschafter job zu machen das
ist ja auch ein job wo man dann wirklich
24 7 in deutschland sein muss so weit
ich ihn kenne ist das nicht sein
lebensentwurf das ist nicht sein
lebensplan aber tatsächlich kein das ist
nicht so einfach und ersatz zu finden
und ich nehme mal an dass das auch noch
eine ganze weile dauern wird und solange
bleibt uns meldet auf jeden fall hatte
er ist doch jetzt schon ein botschafter
die beiden klitschko brüder sind danke
power für den moment für diese exklusive
nachricht aus kiew danke
[Musik]